o olá pessoal daqui fala andar que sejam
muito bem vindos a mais um vídeo e hoje
estamos aqui um vídeo que eu já tô para
fazer a muito tempo eu vou me revelar
aqui para vocês uma caixa onde eu tenho
20 francs para vocês fazer os vossos
amigos ok 20 trollagem para fazer em
casa eu vou recomendar aqui o tem ciúmes
básicos para vocês para fazer é melhor
trollagem a vossa amiga ok mas antes
pessoal deixei um prédio aqui neste
vídeo ok partilhem com vossas amigo
mandei lá no whatsapp sem dizer nada só
mandei para ele e bora lá então eu tenho
aqui muita coisa ok vou mostrar tudo
acompanhe e pega essa pipoca este vídeo
deve ser longo mas vamos ver o que é que
vai dar pessoal e bora lá bora lá então
pessoal a primeira prenda a básica não é
o típico rocam se vocês tiverem bucal em
casa ainda melhor tá aprender a voz
amigo bem claro isso não é só para fazer
em casa vocês também podem levar para
escola ok tudo bem que agora está tudo
em casa em quarentena né então o melhor
é fazer em casa bom enfim está aqui o
código
e vocês podem deixar isto no chão ou uma
muito boa para vocês podem fazer também
é deixar em cima da sanita tipo só no
tempo a pessoa quando abrir para vossa
maior vosso irmão assim ou você amigo
quando eu vir a ser de baixo do tempo
vai ter esse fofinho não era agradável
porque eu avisar que eu não vocês só
falta aqui a semente mesinha semente da
maçã ou o milho o cadinho de milho o meu
está sempre com eles e ficou a primeira
é o forró eu vou deixar aqui tá vou
deixar aqui tudo em cima da mesa que é
para vocês verem bem ao longo do vídeo
para lá próximo ok próxima coisa que eu
tenho aqui e outra coisa eu não vou
testar as frentes aqui nesse vídeo ok
estou apenas a mostrar o meu kit de
frente mas se vocês quiserem ver todas
essas frentes aplicadas aqui em casa
tanto akira como awp com a outra meio
que vem aqui em casa ainda por cima os
upload a casa deles é mesmo aquela que
sempre posso fazer aos vales ou então
não lhe pessoal tudo estava a viver
alguém possa aplicar estes presentes mas
é só vou gravar para o tik tok portanto
se vocês não conseguem no tik tok ou até
embaixo no tik tok é só passar em lá e
eu lá eu vou publicar estas perguntas
todas só que aí eu não vou fazer aqui
bom então passem por lá eu vou postar as
20 prêmios ok continuando a próxima
frank é um anel com água por volta vou
abrir aqui
e vem com dois anéis eu vou colocar aqui
esta caixa de lado é só colocar aqui o
dedo eu acho e nem cabe grande dia do
gordo em casa tem que estar aqui neste
sol assim é discreto é só um anel mesmo
mas aqui por baixo tem um depósito para
vocês podem por água e secar em aqui
alguns levavam usar a água
se bem que eu não sinto mente nenhum
aqui meu essa pergunta é muito boa
pessoal já está bem acompanha lá no tik
tok eu vou usar este toca quer ou trump
drag que eu não sei se funciona é um
sabonete ou o sabão suja a mão já vi um
monte de pessoas a usar este este sabão
mas em muitas não resulta mas também tem
de sabão quando entra em contacto com as
mãos e com água ele suja fica tudo preto
então vocês vão saber se funciona assim
seguiremos eu tenho que toque pessoal e
sofremos muito fáceis para vocês podem
fazer os amigos podem comprar facilmente
em qualquer loja de festas e assim onde
eu comprei essas frango todas muitas
vieram de lixo do ebay também meu anjo
tudo bem curioso pessoal isso aqui é
para vocês colar aí na sanita na parte
de dentro ah eu vou abrir até espera aí
o tampo da sanita fica por cima desta
bisnaga isto cola lá embaixo ok aqui tem
um depósito de água e quando a pessoa se
senta nas anitta vai daqui uns guinchos
que moram foram cuidar pessoas às vezes
tem que eu voltei fazer próxima frente
vocês pode
e eu comprei aqui um tipo de minhocas aí
é uma borracha muito estranha e te
parece mesmo melhor que muita textura
melhor olha aí até aquela parte mais
gelatinosa ok o que é que vocês podem
fazer festas melhor que vocês podem
colocar na comida dentro da sandy eu
acho que o mais indicado é na comida e
tá muito nos mesmo próximo eu tenho que
tanta coisa só vai estar aqui vou ser
sincero esta franca é muito podre olha
eu não sei onde é que eu comprei este
mas eu não tô óculos isso tem que ter
passado mas este não é frente nenhum é
de quem é que vai assustar com isso lá
susto não é muito poder ninguém se
assusta com isso eu decidir colocar aqui
na minha lista só que engraçado outra
frente pessoal essa aqui vendeu esse é o
outro lado que eu tive um slime ó como
podem ver é um ovo consolar eu já fiz um
tik tok até com este vão fazer
e lá como é que esteve de frente vocês
podem fingir então a cozinhar um novo
quente pega na frigideira a tirar uma
frigideira você mim não a frigideira
tira um ovo está dentro da virgindade
não matem o vosso amigo pelo amor de
jesus não adquira que é presa aqui tá
entrou para nossa lista de fé mais eu
estou a tentar despachar isto porque é
muita coisa que eu quero usar muito
tenho aqui uma peça de sushi de arroz e
ovo que é bem comum tem aqui outra peça
de sushi de arroz e ovas de peixe salmão
eu acho que tenho aqui uma ele está
sempre uso aqui que não sei porque eu
acho que eu faço o dinheiro que tem aqui
uma e atum atum parece uma arma né
porque está bem bico do bem durinho sei
que tu deve ser alguém tomate boa enfim
que queres não é para comer ó
e não é não é não é não é plástico zouk
para ser enganar eu tenho patinho em
cima de mim aqui tá da comida eu quero
ir mas tudo de plástico ou seja como é
que vocês podem usar isso vai querer
almoçar com a vossa família em um
restaurante sushi e trocarem as peças
com adicionarem estas e já tá é só isso
é só adicionar em assim também quando
vem aquele tipo aquele menino grande ser
peças é só adicionar a estas eu e com
certeza haverá alguém que vai ficar isto
pode comer a pessoa vai vai a
consciencializar-se as palavras intensa
não é sensibilizar certo tomar
consciência vai consciencializar pronto
vai consciencializar que estas peças são
de plástico aqui talvez vá partir muito
rápido falta qualquer diferença ok é um
conjunto de teias de aranha que serve
para combar outra frente que eu tenho
aqui que é uma aranha de brincar ok
vocês podem utilizar isto com um fio
invisível podem colocar que vai ficar
os nossos pais então basta almofada de
alguém e vocês a noite vão ouvir um
grito e vocês podem utilizar este
presente juntamente com esta está bem
com algumas areias bom enfim usem a
imaginação está aqui próxima praia que
eu já mostrei aqui no canal também tem a
ver com aranhas claramente pode fazer
aqui nesse botão e gostava de ti sim é
só puxar olha ai slime slime ok utiliza
para acessar a nossa vosso pai vós
irmãos especialmente a nossa também
resulta tanto eu não sei porque aranhas
e mãe eu totalmente o oposto então eles
assustam aranha-assistir com a vossa mãe
nossa mãe e susto com aranha e
é porque elas possuem uma da outra mas
bom então pensa uma aranha têm oito
patas e as mães têm duas são aposto que
não amém com e patas também é sua
e não porque não sei mas o que quer
dizer esta também incrível para vocês
fazer a bolsa mas é um cigarro ok
basicamente é para fingir que vocês
fumam só esse não vou deixar prático
toque eu vou eu vou experimentar aqui
porque tudo bem curioso de como é que
isso funciona e acho que não deve fazer
pequeno ele não parece que tá com uma
coisa a certeza mesmo em cima e pensa um
brilho vermelho celular eu acho que eu
tenho colocar aqui farinha dentro e
apertar
bom dia a dia assim eu acho que eu tenho
desse quando era pequenininha eu ver
para as
e não é que não basicamente em colocar
aqui farinha encaixar aqui e tipo sei lá
como isso na mão e depois fiz perfumar e
aperta aqui aí meu deus na frente ok
assim alguns ali no tik tok sim ok é
porque eu não tenho a farinha aqui a mão
contra a clássica buzina de jogo de
futebol ok aquelas buzinas que se levam
postados eu acho que é permitido levar
né não sei eu sempre gosto bora três
azul mas como é que vocês podem utilizar
está em casa ou só faço um só uma coisa
não afonso início do ouvido porque isso
pode causar uma otite dói imenso vocês
podem deixar alguém surdo e fato
qualquer diferente não façam assim perto
de mim eu já me disseram isso é horrível
mais uma prega ainda não acabou ainda
falta muito olha aí temos aqui uma cobra
que eu também comentei da lixo não sei
se já vos mostrei ou não mas esta obra
tá com é realista olha isso tá muito
nisso acho que eu não sei se eu tenho
medo disto mas eu vou aí
o medo acho que eu quero comer ela não
e isso vai cair uma cobra que vocês
podem colocar negócio jardins tiverem
jardim em casa se não tiver em jardim
podem só deixar assim dentro do sapato
do nosso amigo ou tipo de celula basta
dela assim bastante para do só assim já
temos que entrar no quarto dele assim
uma cola esta também é um clássico e
qualquer questão aquelas latas que
aparenta ser recusados o pastilhas um
doce qualquer e ela tem engana porque
parece uma coisas dessas e na verdade
tem mas não é tão as pernas e quando a
pessoa abre ai que susto olho olá
pessoal mais uma franquia é muito boa
basicamente isso é um pacote que aquele
bem comum do mcdonald's e aqui tem que
eu quero saber interminável chamava caio
moro em cima do iphone meu qualquer um
que ter idade portanto dá para usar lá
pelo eu vou abrir a embalagem porque eu
vou usar a etiqueta ok mas está aí esta
também é muito boa esta pergunta foi com
uma mola vem com umas pastilhas vermelha
tá certo para vocês colocarem a mola com
as pastilhas dentro da torneira quando
abrirem tornar a água vai passar pelas
piscinas então vai dar a sensação que
vai sair saindo da torneira meu é muito
assustador se vocês juntar encontra
branca imagina que esperam o sangue e
corrosiva tem aqui também que faz parte
das flex eu tenho aqui uma botija de
sangue sintético ok vocês podem usar
estas em conjunto imaginem mister o
lavatório da casa de banho com sangue e
depois acreditar isso na torneira e a
pessoa vai estar postando tipo de
torneira para lá próximo está quase a
acabar ok aqui está pessoal a minha
favorita aí está assistindo pelo é
realista as pessoas ficam muito à toa
vai fazer o
e parece muito uma língua em qual é
trollagem perfeita para vocês fazerem os
vossos amigos olha só pagar em um palito
para o palito assim eu e olha só o
efeito eu sou uma péssima e depois vocês
ainda podem juntar o sangue eu vou
tentar usar aqui ainda podem juntar os o
meu deus caiu na perna já olha aí olha
aí é incrível e
o url atalho
eu dei uma língua morta com palito uma
rede clássica também só a dentadura para
os nossos amigos acharem que vocês têm
os dentes podres tipo pega um
e aí tão bonito você tava gengiva de
velho oh
é porque se calhar já beijinho vai lá
pessoal o último último aí tempo para
vocês trollar e os nossos amigos ok eu
ainda tenho que ver onde é que posso
utilizar isto mas ainda assim no meu
aniversário se escreve o que é que faz
perguntar shopneu e o mais incrível é
que parece mesmo que ele tem gasto tem
mesmo líquido aqui dentro e ele dá muito
choque tu quer experimentar eu também
não vou experimentar mas quem carregar
aqui meu vai levar um choque da sua vida
vai ser quase morte vem com uma vai cair
vai ficar com o que eu acho que é tudo
pessoal já sabem comentem aí embaixo o
que vocês acharam favorita e já sabe eu
vou utilizar este tudo para vídeos do
tik tok porque não conseguem no tik tok
está aqui em baixo aqui é este aqui na
frente ficam lá pessoal eu vou postar
com todas essas frentes eu tenho aqui
basicamente 25 para fazer tem como acho
que é isso pessoal espero que tenham
gostado a parte também pelo segundo
canal da creme 2.0 então assim vídeos de
terror se vocês gostarem está lá
e fiquem bem e até a próxima